title 42 is a pandemic public health
border policy that keeps most asylum
seekers out of the united states but the
white house now plans to lift it
alexandra limon reports that lawmakers
even some democrats are undermining the
administration and pushing to keep it in
place
[Music]
republican lawmakers are pushing for a
new bill to keep title 42 in place and
they're getting support from some
democrats ensures that title 42 remains
in place
well into the future
while we deal with both a pandemic and
an immigration crisis republicans want
to keep title 42 in place despite
opposing other public health measures
like mask and vaccine mandates why press
for this what is supposed to be a public
health measure as well anybody who would
make that argument is either ignorant or
trying to rationalize their own
hypocrisy all republican senators and at
least seven democrats support extending
title 42 and some are threatening to
vote against the 10 billion dollars in
additional covet funding unless they get
their way what many
senate republicans are talking about is
anti-asylum and i'm going to have to
jump are democrats then also anti-asylum
nevada senator jackie rosen a democrat
said in a statement that the
administration's announcement to end
title 42 was done without a cohesive
strategy in place to secure the border
and prevent chaos but title 42 is a
public health measure and its legal
implementation is not supposed to be for
immigration control maryland senator ben
cardin says that's why the biden
administration is trying to phase it out
people who have legitimate asylum
claims should be able to pursue them in
washington alexandra limon